school starts in less than 24 hours and
this year the Clark County School
District is changing school start times
to account for changing bus schedules
Jeremy J Ford joins us live from the
Arville Transportation yard with how
parents are dealing with these changes
that's right ccs2 CCSD schools start
tomorrow with schedule changes and
earlier school start times and some
parents are currently getting ready to
send their kids off to school a little
bit earlier than usual now this year
some high schools are starting as early
as 7 A.M mostly due to Transportation
issues with CCSD buses and routes
needing to be cut or adjusted although
some parents might find it difficult
getting multiple kids off to school but
the early start times with the early
start times I'm sorry parent Lindsey
Murray tells me she can see how these
changes can affect people's schedules
uh well yes some parents have to go to
work you know earlier than you know
their kids go to school and so it can be
an inconvenience somewhat you know they
have to drop their kids off early at
school you know just to make it to work
on time and stuff so yeah I could see a
it could be an inconvenience
as for parents wondering if their
child's start time has changed you can
go to a link on our page
8newsnow.com for a list of schools in
our area from the bus transportation
center Jeremy J Ford live local now